das ding ist eigentlich find sowas ist
irgendwie kein richtiger prank aber wie
soll man sonst nennen also keine ahnung
ich jetzt einfach mal hoch gucken was
passiert vielleicht wird witzig
vielleicht auch nicht kann ich sagen ja
praktika nah wie jetzt muss die kamera
gegenteil ich mach das irgendwie
ein
hey was geht ab jetzt bekommen beim ein
video ja ich bin gerade hier draußen wir
sind im urlaub immer noch schön hier und
ich habe mir heute was kreatives
überlege ich muss mich ein bisschen
obwohl der woche lang auf jeden fall
habe ich gedacht ich wollte ihr letztes
schon mal irgendwann meinen bruder
bringen hat nicht geklappt weil hat er
irgendwie so ist er hinterher keine
ahnung wie aber hat auf jeden fall nicht
klappt haben für heute gedacht kommen
macht es heute einfach mal ganz locker
lässig und zwar ist es wirklich so der
liegt ohne scheiß jeden tag da der liegt
einfach da und liegt da und macht
eigentlich nicht so viel deswegen hab
ich mir gedacht komm du machst dir
einfach mal so richtig krass
berlin weil ich mal ein bisschen nix
alles gut
und zwar sind wir früher schon immer
hier hoch klettert und ich habe einfach
gestern und kurz einmal genommen und den
da hochgebracht mit dem stuhl und der
war hier jetzt auf jeden fall ist da
ganz viel wasser drin und ich logge dich
einmal zum pool irgendwas finde ich
schon so ich habe hier noch eine woche
hin gestellt also ich denke nicht wenn
der gleich raus läuft dass er die sieht
wenn du bist auch egal ich weitergeben
von wasser ab und zwar bin ich einfach
drüber
berlin
so leute ich bin jetzt hier auf dem dach
das ding ist hier sind irgendwie über
leute und ich hoffe die sagen jetzt
nichts doofes weil ich hier bin ich habe
jetzt hingelegt vorsichtshalber auf
jeden fall ist der eimer und genau unter
mir dass unser appartement und ich
schreibe jetzt mehr erleben mal
irgendwas das herauskommt also leute ich
hab mir jetzt geschrieben komme gleich
zum pool
hier gibt's heftiges neues wlan bei wlan
zieht eigentlich an
also hier geht es runter kommt nicht aus
2000 jahre später vollkommen deswegen
gering
du solltest mal rauskommen aus der
schweiz wurde wird jetzt in cool
ernsthaft ich dachte oh verbessert sich
irgendwas sagen was scheiße von die
leute das war's mit diesem video
ich hoffe es hat euch ein bisschen
gefallen so klar es war irgendwie dumm
aber ich habe es jetzt immerhin erreicht
dass er mit mir im pool geht beginnen
grüne an sonst würde ich noch sagen also
jetzt wieder sagen
fake oder so ist wie es wirklich ist ein
echtes wasser das wasser war rhiel
es war wirklich echtes wasserkasten und
das dach so hier war wirklichen darf
also ich halte lasters auf jeden fall
will ich sagen willst du noch alter
warum bist du so gut
das wars mit dem video einen pc